so I had these gloves right and there
are decent pair of gloves you know
they're good at keeping my hands warm
which is you know what I need them for
during this winter period they're
waterproof so the good good when it
comes to snow and they're just generally
you know a decent pair of gloves and not
only are they a decent pair of gloves
but I also got them for free because my
dad gave them to me so you know just
generally these are these are an awesome
pair of gloves but as well as having an
awesome pair of gloves I have this
friends could Lex who basically likes to
pick holes in everything that I do in
everything that I am I mean don't get me
wrong she's lovely but that's just a
sense of humor being the kind of girl
that she is when she saw that I owned
these gloves she um she she she made fun
of them in quite a big way because even
though they are quite good pair of
gloves they do look a little bit silly
but you know obviously that's not
important to me right because the
important thing is having warm hands
during winter that's that that's the
that's the important important thing so
obviously I bought myself a new pair of
gloves
now I ended up going for a pair of
gloves that I have wanted that I wanted
to own for about eight years ever since
I watched Pokemon on the TV and I saw
ash Ketcham with his little finger 'less
gloves right though I'm crying about his
little pokeballs I have wanted a pair of
fingerless gloves because I thought that
they were the the bee's knees
that they were the top dog as far as you
could go in in in the glove in the glove
world
so let me just tell you right these
gloves are without a doubt the worst
pair of gloves that I have ever bought
in my entire life and yes I've only ever
bought one pair of gloves but these
gloves are terrible what is the point of
owning a pair of gloves don't keep your
hands warm I never understand right well
they didn't put a little label next to
these gloves saying just just by the way
these clubs will not do anything to help
keep your hands warm at all which is
probably the reason that you want
clothes but they don't actually help and
I don't understand why nobody told me
this beforehand right because I'm pretty
sure I've seen my friends wearing
fingerless gloves like around about
right I don't underst it just makes me
sad right that I now own a piece of
clothing
thing for me except look good which is
not why I like clothes I like clothes
because they keep me warm because they
cover up my naked body but because they
look good I hate any kind of accessories
all that kind of stuff you know I don't
I'm not into any kind of fashion or any
of this stuff I just like clothes the
clothes and the thing that makes me the
saddest about this whole whole thing
right is the fact that I will wear these
gloves and I'll be out with my friends
you know and they'll see my hands and
they'll see how awful red my fingertips
are and I'll say Charlie Charlie are you
are your hands cold and I'll say yes yes
they are and then they'll say well why
are you wearing those gloves then and I
will say I don't I don't know I don't
know